the Maine secretary of state has barred
president Donald Trump from the ballot
as the Supreme Court weighs State
authority to block the former president
from elections joining us now is the
chairman of the house oversight
committee the congressman from Kentucky
James comr chairman comr what's your
initial reaction to this ruling out of
Maine well I'm not surprised I fear
we're going to see this happen in more
States uh but I'll tell you it's good
for every member of Congress especially
me to be back home during Christmas
listening to average Americans and I'm
here in Kentucky right now and if you
ask the average Kyan uh about the
Democrats uh and and what they're trying
to do right now they especially with
respect to the presidential race they'll
say two things first of all they think
it's absurd what the Democrats are
trying to do in blue States in Banning
president Trump from the ballot I mean
this is clearly election interference
and then the second thing that the
average person on the street will say
about the Democrat in in this
presidential race is they've got a
problem with their candidate Joe Biden
poll after poll shows that the Americans
believe his policies are bad and that
even worse for Joe Biden he's a crook so
uh I I think that the Democrats are
trying to do everything they can in a
last ditch effort to disrupt uh the
Republican momentum right now heading
into the presidential election I think
this is another example of that and I I
hate to say it Jason but I I fear we're
going to see more blue States pull
stunts like this
yeah the projection from the Democrats
was that this is the kind of stunt that
Donald Trump would pull but no it's
actually the Democrats that are pulling
this I want to actually read what the
Dem what the main Secretary of State
said about this process because um you
know she regarded Trump that he had
committed so-called
Insurrection this is a quote Trump's
objections hinge largely on the rules of
evidence that do not govern this
proceeding the fact that a report
includes hearsay contains irrelevant
facts or lack Foundation does not
automatically render it an admissible
rather the central question is whether
it is the type of evidence on which
reasonable persons are accustomed to
rely in serious Affairs I rule the
January 6 report meets this standard and
again Donald Trump was never charged nor
was he ever convicted of anything let
alone
Insurrection I where she's coming from
this is the kind of stuff that you do do
in a Banana Republic and when they do
the United States calls it out as
something that is totally
unacceptable yeah I mean the hypocrisy
coming from Democrat leaders around the
country with respect to election
interference is breathtaking I mean all
they tried to insinuate if you go back
to the president the last presidential
election remember they tried to say that
uh uh when President Trump appointed
lisis dejoy to be Postmaster General
they were going to steal the election in
election ballots in absentee ballots
well election I they were pretty
satisfied the Democrats were with the
percentage of of votes that Joe Biden
got with mail-in ballot so they just
dropped that now they're going with this
uh Insurrection narrative that's
completely bogus I mean I was there
January 6 and January 6th was a rally
that went bad that's what it was it
wasn't an organized event if it were the
Democrats would have proven that in
their January 6th committee hearings
remember the Democrats in the January
6th committee uh debacle they deposed
president Trump's family for 24 hours so
president Trump's kids and and in-laws
came in and sat for depositions for 24
hours here in our investigation as you
know Jason uh we have all this
disturbing evidence of political
corruption by the Biden family we have
given the President Biden's son a lawful
subpoena and he defied that subpoena so
I think the American people are seeing
this hypocrisy play out uh in a in a
live basis here with what we saw in
Maine what we've seen in in Colorado I'm
sure there are going to be other states
we see Democrat tweets and Democrat
politicians encouraging Democrat
secretaries of state and liberal Supreme
Court to do this just to try to create a
narrative that uh that the Republicans
are a threat to
democracy well I think it's going to be
interesting chairman as you dive into
this what did Joe Biden know about it
you had a duly issued subpoena that was
issued out there uh for Hunter Biden to
appear and now the White House
spokesperson well she's saying that the
president was you know was he involved
was he engaged was he I think that's a
legitimate question I wish we had more
time to dive into it but I know it's
something you're going to look into it
Merry Christmas Happy New Year chairman
James comr appreciate you joining us hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else